[Music]
randall is going to start us off this
hour in cincinnati ohio home of the
super bowl bound bingles oh my goodness
taking the nfl by storm
randall how can we help
thanks for starting that way guys uh who
day by the way there it is i i knew we
had a shot at the who day and so you
just delivered beautifully sir for sure
for sure um so
i inherited a home for my mother who
passed away in december
for the full year prior to her passing
she had dementia
and both of my brothers are living in
that home they are not
receiving that inheritance via her will
uh one of them had taken advantage of
her
um in the last six months and completely
depleted 35 000 out of her bank account
and so i'm stuck uh with this house and
just not sure what to do
not sure what direction to go with uh
with the brother who has stolen
uh and so i'm just kind of kind of
overwhelmed with it and i'd like to get
your guys advice yeah quick point of
clarification john
so randall do i understand that you
inherited the house in the will
you perfect yes okay and the two
brothers are living in it
correct okay yeah and so first i want to
say sorry about your mother's loss man
how did she pass away thank you
uh her heart stopped um i mean there
were complications from the dementia she
was getting pretty bad off but
um you know with various medications and
so on and and she just her heart
eventually just gave out okay
so what's your relationship like with
your brothers and it's an important
context for how i'm going to suggest you
move forward here
um my oldest brother who is
not the
guilty party
he i have a great relationship with him
i talk with him pretty frequently my
middle brother
it's very strained at the moment okay as
it should be because he stole 35 000
from your mother
his mom right and i'll go one step
further were both of these brothers
living with her during this time
yes yeah i i would suggest older
brothers got some
is complicit in this too
either through
not stepping up or not saying hey no
chance you know what i mean not being
involved in this deal
yeah um so it was mainly my middle
brother who was who was doing most of
her caretaking he was without work my
older brother was working
and contributing as much as he could but
for the most part it was my middle
brother who was doing that and he
i almost think that he feels like he was
owed that money because he was the one
doing all the the medical stuff and
taking her to appointments and and doing
all that yeah and you come to that
conclusion when all the kids sit down
and say here's how we're gonna handle
the next six months of care and then at
month four and a half or five you sit
down have that meeting again and say
how's everybody doing
and he just decided he was gonna start
billing his mother for care he could be
unemployed living rent free billing mom
by stealing from her and that's
the way addicts that's the way thieves
justify their behavior
so there's a reason why your mom left
you this house and didn't split it up
amongst the boys is that right
yeah okay
so
the you've heard me say this before i'll
say it again it's not by your hand but
in your lap
you didn't cause this problem
you're a person of integrity integrity
and character and that's why your mom
trusted you with her home
and
at this point you have to decide do i
want to be the landlord of a thief
and somebody's not paying attention to
mom or are you going to sell the house
tell them hey you guys got 30 days i'm
evicting you i'm selling this house and
i'm moving on with my life even if you
want to split up and give them some of
the money if you think that's the right
thing to do but i'm gonna wash my hands
to this house and we're moving on with
it but i think that's your only option
right now
yeah i was coming to that conclusion
mike my concern was you know do i what
do i do with my brother do i how old is
he give him money
uh he's 51 and my oldest brother is 54.
it's time for you to stop taking care of
him
he's a yeah he's a big boy why would you
give him money yeah instead of instead
of asking us well i mean if you should
why would you
yeah it's the
it's the heart issue i i just feel so
bad that he would be going out on the
street and i feel like i'm forced to
kick him on the street he's well robbed
your mom whoa
is there anything in the will
any kind of directive or suggestion from
your mom
that uh when she decided for you to take
care of the estate specifically the
house that you were supposed to sell it
and split the profits is there any
direction at all
no it was just for the goods within the
home that we were supposed to split the
house was so split the goods yeah
supposed to split the goods so here's
here's what the will said uh and this is
what we're doing sell this and here's
your proceed if you want to give him
your cut just because you feel bad i
mean this is more my colleague's take
but i'm just going to common sense this
this isn't the counselor approach but
it's like you don't owe this 51 year old
brother
anything other than what the will
specifically lays out as it relates to
the goods inside the house outside of
that this is up to your discretion and
and you have to decide
am i going to
base my relationship
uh with my brother going forward
on me giving him more money
than that he doesn't actually deserve or
have any right to after he's already
stolen money i i just i don't think you
should lose any sleep over this at all
really the right thing and i say right
in a not a moral ethical but the right
from a justice perspective is you call
the police
and you say that my this man stole 35
000 from my mother over the course of
six months
and i'd like it investigated
that's what justice would say
you sitting down and saying your free
ride at 51 is over and it's time for you
to get a job and against your own place
and if i guess i get the
the will says
this and i also get being a brother
saying if how much is this house worth
uh about 140. yeah so i can i can
imagine you holding 140 000 and watching
your brothers move out right and that'd
be hard and you'd think well they
deserve something well technically you
know his cut he ought to take the 35 000
out of his cut ooh i like that i was
giving you each 36 out of 35 000 and
five dollars and you can give your
brother one brother a five dollar bill
and the other brother 35 grand and high
five him until him some other way but
there is a reason here while your mother
left you this money these problems don't
come out of a vacuum someone just
doesn't decide to take advantage of
their dying mother has he been like this
for
a while
um really it's just developed over the
last six months to be honest with you
that i know of um from from bank records
why did she change no no i'm talking
about just a little bit squirrely a
little bit
out of work a little bit hey mom i need
to move back in a lot of 51 living with
mom
yeah i mean he's had various various
issues
he had a surgery he broke his ankle and
that eventually led to more
problems uh so he's had some medical
issues
within the last 10 years is why he's
went back with her okay um so
yeah
you're in the middle the situation got
dropped in your lap brother and i think
the right thing to do is to tell them
hey guys it's time to find a new place
i'm selling this house you can come up
with the split if you think that's
necessary i don't think it is especially
to the to the brother stole from your
mom
um but you got to sleep well at night
so sorry for your loss ramble